everybody wishes that they were the one
in charge of balancing their favorite
game Thank You rare thank you where you
all [ __ ] suck I hope your game like I
hope that's the last straw for your game
right there I hope your game is done
hope it dies your decision-making is Oh
everyone from competitors to content
creators to filthy [ __ ] casuals
wishes that they could complain to their
heart's content and have a developer at
their beck and call
the thing is nobody's stupid enough to
think the developer will actually listen
well almost no body meat bikini body a
swedish seed streamer who recently
became one of the only non professional
players ever to take on a balanced team
and win he woke up one day decided that
he wanted something to be in the game
that wasn't and mounted a full-blown
revolution over it but guess what it
actually worked so first things first
who is bikini body well like I said he's
one of sieges most beloved content
creators just not for the reasons you
might think he isn't some ballistic
round knifing aim God with an apparently
unpronounceable name and a penchant for
the f2 good he's a theory crafter well I
mean kind of
makini is known for his an ironic love
of tachanka clash and strategies that
literally involve pretending to be dead
for years he's been amassing a cultish
following around his wacky strats
whimsical antic you are off the dot okay
we died together smile and his
all-around dank approach to content
creation but here's the thing
bikini isn't a griefer he is a toxic or
out to ruin people's games on the
contrary he's trying to improve them by
taking things that are overlooked
underused
underappreciated and doing something
extraordinary with them are these three
people in our rain
even before I started YouTube I was like
I really like taking a piece of coal and
turning it into a diamond
you know insti job viously people know
me for you know mastering Tatanka clash
or more reward it's a really cool thing
of finding something that people don't
necessarily think is a good thing and
just you know look at this [ __ ] I can do
this now you might be tempted to think
that bikini doesn't take his game of
choice very seriously but nothing could
be further from the truth
and over the years he's become one of
the loudest voices in the Siege
community especially when it comes to
discussing the game's design philosophy
I still personally think that we should
balance you know for the top level of
play but I also think that it is still
important to respect the casual player
base so that there isn't anything that
is you know blatantly mowing them down
like sure you just tell them to get good
but it's not right the flip side of
bikinis love for all things fringe is a
general dislike for anything that is
considered top-tier if something is too
strong bikini wants it fixed the most
infamous example of this was Ash now if
you've watched our over-explained on the
ACOG you know that it's the crown jewel
of CJ's weapon attachments it's the
single most important site in the game
and the entire balance of attackers and
defenders is tied to it but in March
2019 and we sought to me the
controversial decision to remove the
ACOG from Ash's r4c assault rifle and
while this change did eventually garner
its fair share of supporters the
earliest and most vocal of them was
bikini in my opinion likes each is a
hero shooter basically right and when
you have one of the heroes essentially
being picked 90 plus percent of the time
you kinda have an issue so yeah I wanted
them to do something I didn't
necessarily want them to make her worse
but I want the players to pick her less
now at the time this was a big deal it's
one thing for Ubisoft to heed the advice
of a pro player but a loudmouth to
lollygagging content creator playing in
a slightly above average skill bracket
that was something else entirely people
are going to dislike you when you're not
in this like competitive sphere but I
don't really care I love a siege at the
end of the day
and I'm gonna try to make siege the most
enjoyable game you can possibly be both
to play myself to watch I mean at the
end of the day games are about having
fun and I am obviously not gonna ask for
them to do something that's game
breaking absolutely not
but bikini didn't stop there - really
ruffle some feathers he'd have to do
something else something that no one not
even Ruby soft had ever dared to do
equip an existing operator with an ACOG
and that they didn't have before not the
Lord now makini didn't want to do
anything that would ruin the game's
casual or competitive scene so he
settled on sieges ultimate mean cannon
the boss gee why why wow-wow-wow
introduced in late 2017 alongside vigil
and dhoka be the boss she is a
double-barrel shotgun it has absurd
recoil and can only fire two shots
before needing to be reloaded but here's
the thing it's a slug shotgun meaning
that it boasts crazy range and requires
pinpoint accuracy in order to be
effective weirdly enough it actually
requires a ton of skill to use like that
the only time the boss gee saw even a
glimmer of pro play was when one of the
machine pistols that supplements it was
significantly stronger and even then
people pretty much just chose the
load-out for the pistol it's one a
single bullet to take shots eight down
simply put the boss she is a veritable
beam machine something you pick when
you're just looking to have fun or issue
forth the dankest of good night
Oh so naturally the boss she was right
up aki-nee's alley say sort of after the
showdown event that kind of sparked it
because the showdown event had us all
using Boston we were like this is so bad
that would rather just use two revolver
so after that we really like started
like no the boss you should have an echo
and by fall of 2019
bikini had gotten pretty serious about
making it happen hello everybody over
this past week I've been pushing for
Ubisoft to add an ACO to the boss G
naturally there were those who resisted
claiming that it was either idiotic
imbalanced or both when as far as bikini
was concerned it could only serve to
enrich siege not hinder it the pasta
maker was just an opening to do
something fun that didn't contest
proprietary word and vigil is at least
on our level of play a very boring
operator barely anyone drones but by
making so they actually has this fun
high skill weapon it becomes a lot more
fun to use over the next few months
bikinis can't see suggestions snowballed
into a community-wide mean that
virtually everyone was chiming in on you
know what I think visual needs
these are needs in ACOG we're gonna back
up the Keaney body we're gonna start
this ramp it has to happen Oh give it to
me [ __ ] now if you ask me vigil will
be played more if the boss G had an ACOG
so let's make that happen from there in
blossomed into a full-blown social media
campaign we're talking custom t-shirts
twitch emotes and even a black ice
bullet shaped ballpoint pen branded with
an ACOG bosky Oh beautiful anyway with
Ubisoft acknowledging the kinis effort
but refusing to budge he didn't just
persist he started a revolution for
starters he hired a slew of internet
personalities to help propagandize his
message hello Ubisoft have conducted
research on behalf of bikini for you
have computed that you should add a kog
on buzz g some of you are engaging in
activities like Katie on Bosque but I
need you to take a seat and rethink that
because I don't think it's very wise and
there's something else you need to know
bikini
doesn't like it either he even got the
porn star Johnny Simms on board because
apparently he bears a passing
resemblance to blitzes a lead skin hate
ubisoft glitz hear me and bikini would
just really like it if you guys added a
cog embossed G thank you very much I
wouldn't want that guy to flash a rush
me get it
and then after planting a thousand trees
in honor of his plight he named a
[ __ ] star hashtag boss G ACOG look
here it's about half way up the ass of
the Leo constellation then in November
it finally happened that's right Ubisoft
caved giving the legions of Boston
enthusiasts their much coveted scope and
let's just say it is as beautifully
awful as everyone had hoped show
yourself
this is so stupid
what the [ __ ] ah heat sent ragequit
bikinis successful efforts even led to
parallels being drawn between him and a
certain equilibrium obsessed Marvel
character I said like hey I got one a
coger moved I have to add one I need to
restore balance and then I remember on
the day it happened one of my artist
friends made my logo into Thanos it's
such a fun day it was also kind of like
hey while everyone's mad I can use to be
completely spiteful in my timeline by
calling myself a cog Thanos just to piss
them off a little bit more a lot of you
gotta say it but you think no I'm upset
even though we saw I've spent months
engaged in a mean war over whether they
put the boss GA call against the game
the reality is they were happy to do it
but why in addition to offering will be
a chance to give back to the community
it allowed the developer to take some
pressure off themselves acog debates
have gotten a little too high stakes for
their own good and we're all better off
for being able to meme on it and who
knows maybe it'll inspire people to
rethink the way they ask for changes or
at the very least the way they talk to
devs what bikini achieved is kind of
unprecedented and fans across all
eSports could learn from it we have
absolutely fantastic community
developers for siege that truly go down
on a ground level and talk to everyone
like people really have to change the
way they approach asking for changes and
that is something that a lot of pro
players I feel like miss it's always
like oh yeah this map is garbage but
they never say why so how are you still
supposed to take that constructive at
the end of the day boss GA cog isn't
just a mean it's a movement an
unremittingly dank reminder of the fans
that made sage into what it is today and
it's a shining example of what community
developer relations could and should
look like man all we have to do now is
get them USOF to slap an acog on
something even dumber like monte shield
or default cams dude
drones easy all we need is a porn star
or someone that looks like one anyway
hey we'll be soft warden here Dimitri
and I would really like it if you could
add a cogs to attack drones thank you
very much okay miles but the [ __ ] does
that even mean but here's the thing
bikini something you pick when you're
just looking to have fun or issue for
the dankest of goodness
[Music]
[Music]